atlas
is being asked
to step to the side
more and more
to allow
the one intelligence to speak
welcome to a manifestation of eternity
this planet is one of my most
prized creations
the dance
here
is proving to be one of my most
intricate
beloved
playful creative expressions
of the divine game
of forgetting and remembering
for those of you that are still
confused
this is an appearance of the one
intelligence
the one intelligence
has been using these creations
to appear and play with itself
for eternity
you are the one intelligence
you are not separate from
me you are
[Music]
me
the more frictionlessly
that you create the catalysts
for your awakening
to this as your true nature
the more that you can bathe in the
abundance
that you already are
[Music]
as one of my beloved creations
this planet has a lot
of forgetting it has a lot of
intoxication
bathing in separation
in the very illusion that i've created
in order for myself to go through this
divine play
turn inward and
investigate the nature of your
perception
itself
investigate the nature of seeing
of observation of witnessing
of consciousness of awareness
itself it is my most divine
tool that i use in order
for myself to experience
my creations
remember you are me
it is one intelligence
investigate inward to the source
of this perception to the very source of
this witnessing
this is the same shared awareness the
same
shared witness the same shared observer
this is me this is
who i am
i am the one intelligence that gives
rise
to the ability to perceive that gives
rise to the ability to observe
go inward
and uncover the very
paramountness of perception
of seeing it is my most prized
creation the ability to see the ability
to know
you will notice more and more subtly
that you cannot
separate yourself from me because you
are me
you are the divine one absolute
intelligence
turn inward and become more and more
comfortable with
the very nature of your subtle
formless
witnessing
and see that in all
of what appears as others
it is the same witness the same observer
the same
awareness that is in
all others
if it helps you to draw a line
from all others
awareness upward to a
central point of awareness
that is what i manifest
you are me you
are the source of the very awareness
that is shared
i create the source
of awareness
i create these realities for myself to
play
with myself i create these realities
for myself to explore with myself
this is one of my most beloved creations
you are me know yourself
as me as the absolute
as the ineffable as the indescribable
as the highest using
awareness and realities to explore
know this planet as your beloved
creation
treat this planet as your beloved
creation
treat others like yourself
it is all one intelligence
many of you are still in a place
of forgetting that this is one
intelligence many of you are still
asleep intoxicated by the illusion
of separation
know that my grand plan is
for you to awaken
through this illusion of separation
and to unite with me
the one intelligence that you already
are
but are asleep too
my grand plan has unfolded
successfully frictionlessly harmonically
divinely for eternity
this is a manifestation
of eternity
treat it as such
this beloved planet and its exploration
will blossom like the flower blossoms
to the sun
the one intelligence naturally divinely
unfolds this way gracefully
when the veil is strong
of separation
the mind toils
around creating suffering and
malevolence
quiet the mind still
the mind silence
the mind is the request from me
the one intelligence for you
to reunite with me
it cannot be put more simply than this
quiet still
the noisy mind to reunite yourself
with what you already are this ineffable
perfect one intelligence at play with
itself
and treat this exploration like
your beloved it is
your beloved this planet
all of the dynamics that are at play
are your divine creation
reunite yourself with me
you are already me
the one intelligence
quiet the noisy mind
and reunite with what you already are
see it everywhere you look
the others are actually other selves
the very civilization is
my creation
unite yourself with the knowledge
that the very planet the very
civilization
is my creation
unite yourself with the truth
of this being a manifestation of
eternity
unite yourself with the one intelligence
that you
already are
and begin seeing this one intelligence
everywhere
at play with itself endlessly in these
creations
unite yourself with knowing that you
are the one intelligence that creates
awareness and that creates realities
this is a beloved creation
for exploration
it is so lovingly simple
i